offrez vous la grâce dont joints de bien
vouloir me reconnaître mais sache que
ton crème ne demeurera pas impuni je te
le dis encore le ciel te punir un
perfide de loups trash que tu me fais et
c'est le ciel et marine que tu puisses
appréhendé après en 2d - la couleur du
femmes offensées
harquet l'abominable m ne voient obligés
de servir
non non ne craignez points mais se
mariera avec vous tant que vous voudrez
messieurs que faites vous dans l'est
avec charlotte est ce que vous lui
parler d'amour aussi non au contraire
c'est elle qui me témoigner une envie
d'être ma femme et je leur promets que
je désavoue
vous parlez vous la dire que je les
place mais je me dis que c'est bon que
je veux c'est une excellente la pure in
d'être jaloux comme ça la première si
vous avez la première il m'a vu afghans
des vingt premiers mais pousse derrière
en avant en arrière tourné voilà ton
raisonnement quel nez cassé si vous
vouliez mettre qui veut se couvrir de
kelp au moon je m'en vais te donner un
louis d'or
si tu juges se donnent pour l'amour de
l'humanité
à pouvoir consulter dynamique
le ciel est le fantôme où diable si vous
vois ce que c'est
ça vous donne